digamos que tengo tres líneas en r2 y
quiero encontrar la intersección de
todas ellas es decir quiero hallar el
punto en donde las tres coinciden y
digamos que la primera es 2x menos o
igual a 2
digamos que las siguientes x + 2 igual a
no será 1 y que la tercera es x + ye
igual a 4 ok entonces vamos a graficar
estas tres rectas pero antes quiero
expresar las de la forma que igual a mx
más b porque para mí es mucho más
sencillo mucho más sencillo de
entenderlas entonces por ejemplo de aquí
si despejamos la aie tendremos primero
menos igualados menos 2 x o podríamos
ponerlo como menos 2 x más 2 ok y esto
finalmente pues si cambiamos el signo de
ambos lados tendremos que igual a 2x
menos 2 muy bien ahora en la siguiente
en la siguiente tendremos
22 yenes despejamos 2 y el x pasa
restando y tendremos menos x + 1 o bien
si pasamos el 2 dividiendo tenemos igual
a menos un medio de x +
ok eso dividiendo por uno por un medio
de ambos lados y finalmente en esta de
aquí abajo tendremos ya igual a 4 - x s
es bastante sencillo de analizar
entonces vamos a graficar todo esto
digamos que aquí tengo
uno de mis ejes quedó un poco chueco
uno de mis ejes y aquí está
el otro eje digamos este es el eje x ok
este de aquí es el eje y muy bien
entonces esta forma me dice exactamente
por donde pasan por ejemplo la primera
línea que es la morada pasa por menos
dos entonces aquí está -1 y -2 y además
tiene pendiente dos quiere decir que por
cada uno de x subimos dos de iu entonces
si nos movemos uno de x por ejemplo aquí
subimos dos de iu entonces es esta recta
que toca a estos dos puntos
más o menos de esta forma ahora vámonos
con la recta verde esta pasa por un
medio entonces pasa si aquí anda el 1
esta pasará por aquí y además tiene
pendiente menos un medio eso quiere
decir que va hacia abajo y que por cada
uno de iu son 2 de x entonces por cada
uno de ellos son 2 de x
2 entonces si bajamos 1 tenemos más o
menos estoy de hecho si se dan cuenta
esta tiene una pendiente y bueno estas
dos son ortogonales verdad está
pendiente es menos 1 entre esta otra
pendiente entonces más o menos se deben
ver ortogonales
más o menos
más o menos son ortogonales ahí se ven
verdad muy bien y ahora vámonos con esta
última línea que es la azul ye igual a 4
- x eso quiere decir que pasa por el 4 1
2 3 4 y que pasa por menos perdón que
tiene pendiente menos 1 entonces quiere
decir que pasa por ejemplo por el 1 2 3
esta línea de aquí vamos a ver si nos
sale como dibujarla
y digo está un poquito chueca pero pero
el punto es los hijos
más o no
ok vamos a hacerlo otra vez porque esta
línea salió muy mal
más o menos de esta forma y si
extendemos bien esto nos podemos dar
cuenta de que en realidad no hay una
intersección entre las tres líneas no la
hay entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
bueno podríamos rendirnos y decir bueno
pues no la hay ni modo o bien decir
aunque no la haya podemos dar un punto
que sería la mejor aproximación que
podríamos dar ok y entonces estaremos
pensando en utilizar la técnica de los
mínimos cuadrados que desarrollamos en
el vídeo anterior y entonces tú dirás
bueno dónde está la ecuación a x igual a
b pero está implícita en este sistema de
ecuaciones y eso es porque tenemos una
matriz que multiplica a un vector xy y
que nos da otro vector si lo da si lo
ves es un sistema de ecuaciones que que
lo podemos expresar de la siguiente
forma
tenemos una matriz tenemos una matriz
una matriz que multiplica a un vector xy
y que me da el vector 214 ok 214 muy
bien y ahora tenemos que ver cuáles son
los coeficientes de esta matriz entonces
el primero será 2 el 2 multiplica x y
menos 1 hay dos y menos 1 el siguiente
será 1 y 2 1 y 2 y el siguiente será 1 y
1 1 y 1 muy bien entonces esta es
nuestra matriz
este es nuestro vector x y este es el
vector b entonces por supuesto si
hubiera una solución querría decir que
hay un punto en donde las tres rectas se
intersectan entonces el sistema x igual
a b no tiene solución no tiene solución
no tiene solución
sin embargo aunque no tenga una solución
lo que podríamos intentar es dar una
solución que aunque no sea tal cual una
solución sino que es la más cercana a lo
que podría ser este este vector ok
que sería la proyección de nuestro
vector b es decir queremos encontrar un
x que satisface la ecuación que
encontramos anteriormente es verdad que
era multiplicar esta ecuación por atrás
pues está del lado izquierdo y entonces
este x si es la solución se vuelve la
solución por mínimos cuadrados ok a
transpuesta por b
y entonces buscamos esta solución muy
bien entonces quien sería a transpuesta
a transpuesta fíjense que éste es a
entonces a transpuesta sería esta matriz
la 211 menos 1 2 1 es decir columnas se
vuelven renglones y multiplicamos por
nuestra matriz a por nuestra matriz a
que es ella misma pero bien paradito ok
- 1 2 1 y ahora multiplicamos al vector
x estrella verdad pero bueno vamos a ver
cuánto nos da esta multiplicación esto
es una matriz de 2 x 3 y esta es una
matriz de 3 por 2 por lo tanto me va a
dar una matriz de 2 x 2
una matriz de 2 por 2 vamos a ver es
este renglón hacemos producto punto con
esta columna y es dos por dos cuatro más
uno por uno es uno y llevamos cinco y
uno por uno es uno y los cinco nos da
seis aquí ahora bien este renglón con
esta columna y es 2 por menos 1 es menos
2 y 1 por 2 es 2 esos se cancelan y
finalmente me queda uno por uno que es 1
vamos con este renglón y esta columna es
menos 2 bueno es menos 1 por 2 que es
menos dos y dos por uno es 2 eso se
cancelan y me queda uno por uno que es 1
y finalmente este renglón por esta
columna que es menos uno por menos uno
es 1 2 por dos es cuatro y uno por uno
es 1 si sumamos todo nos da 6 esta es la
matriz a transpuesta ahora muy bien
ahora tenemos que ver quién es a
transpuesta por b
vamos a ver quién es a transpuesta que
es la matriz ésta que tenemos aquí
arriba
1 - 1 2 1 y lo multiplicamos por nuestro
vector b quién era el vector b se
encuentra acá arriba el 2 1 4 es el 2 14
verdad ahora bien esta es una matriz de
2 x 3 y esta es una matriz de 3 por 1
entonces me va a quedar un vector de 2
por 1
saleh vamos a hacer esto un poco más
abajo entonces me va a quedar un vector
de 2 por 1
ahí está ok y esto igual que en el caso
anterior simplemente vamos a hacer
renglón por columna y nos queda 2 x 2 es
cuatro más uno por uno es 1 y 1 por 4 es
4 entonces tenemos cuatro más uno más
cuatro que es
ahora vamos con este es menos 1 por 2 es
menos 2 y 2 por 1 es 12 eso se cancela y
finalmente me queda 1 por 4 que es 4
entonces este vector
este es el ha transpuesto por ver muy
bien y finalmente lo que obtuvimos es ya
una ecuación porque esta matriz es la
matriz
116 que multiplica al vector xy que es
el que queremos descubrir y esto debe
ser igual a transpuesta por ver que es 9
y aquí 4 muy bien entonces vamos a
resolver esto como ya sabemos es
utilizando operaciones con matrices
simplemente escribimos la matriz
aumentada verdad de esta forma la matriz
aumentada y vamos a tratar de escalonar
la entonces si nos damos cuenta este
este día este renglón ya tiene un 1
entonces lo primero que me gustaría
hacer es intercambiar los renglones y si
lo vamos escribiendo de esa forma
entonces el primer paso digamos tenemos
simplemente intercambiando los renglones
tenemos esto así 61 y 9 verdad sólo
intercambian los renglones ahora ahora
lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar el
primer renglón por menos 6 y sumarse lo
al segundo renglón entonces si yo
multiplico por menos 6 el primer renglón
tengo menos 6 y si se lo sumo a éste me
queda 0 déjenme copiar primero el primer
renglón que se no le hacemos nada
y ahora si uno por menos 6 es menos 66
es 0 6 por menos 6 es menos 36 más 1 es
menos 35 y ahora 4 por menos 6 es menos
24 y hay que sumarle 9 entonces tengo
menos 24 más 9 esto es lo mismo bueno
menos 24 menos 9 son 15 verdad entonces
aquí va un -15 vámonos ahora hacia el
lado derecho
vámonos ahora hacia el lado derecho
digamos hacia acá y lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es en el segundo renglón
multiplicar por menos 1 sale entonces el
primer renglón lo dejamos igual
dejamos igual y si multiplicamos por
menos uno aquí me da cero o más bien
vamos a multiplicar por menos uno entre
35 verdad para que aquí me quede un 1 y
simplemente me queda menos 15 entre
menos 35 menos 15 entre menos 35 los
menos se cancelan y si dividimos entre 5
arriba y abajo aquí me queda 3 y aquí me
queda 7 verdad
entonces esto es lo que ya pudimos hacer
ahora vamos a dejarlo vamos a resolverlo
completamente porque ahora vamos a
multiplicar el renglón de abajo por
menos 6 y sumarlo al de arriba entonces
este se queda igual
y nos queda 3 séptimos y ahora 0 x
dijimos menos 60 y si se lo sumamos al
alumno nos queda el 11 por menos 6 es
menos 66 nos da 0 y ahora 3 séptimos por
menos 6 eso eso nos da
- 18 séptimos verdad y esto en séptimos
el 4 en séptimos simplemente es 28
séptimos ya ese le vamos a restar 6 por
318 séptimos y esto sólo son 10 séptimos
verdad entonces aquí arriba me quedan 10
séptimos y con esto con esto ya hay la
solución de esta ecuación la solución
está dada de la siguiente forma como x
estrella x estrella es la que tiene como
coordenada en x 10 séptimos 10 séptimos
y como coordenada en 3 séptimos muy bien
esta es mi solución que que la más
cercana a una solución posible del
problema original que no existe no
existe pero es lo que sería lo más
cercano a una solución verdad sobre el
espacio columna como lo vimos ya en el
vídeo anterior esto minimiza los
cuadrados colectivos entre entre las
posibilidades del espacio columna vamos
a ver
es ahora en realidad nuestra diferencia
minimizada ok vamos a ver cuál es la la
en realidad la cantidad que se minimiza
es decir
recordemos que el punto central era
minimizar esta expresión a x estrella
menos b si quizás lo escribí como b - a
x estrella pero como es una norma no
importa entonces todavía nosotros no
tenemos quienes a x estrella pero
sabemos que a es la matriz ésta está
roja de aquí entonces es 211 menos 121
tenemos 22 11 - 1 2 1
y que multiplica a este vector que es el
10 séptimos 10 séptimos 3
y vamos a ver cuánto vale esto entonces
este bueno hacemos renglón por columna y
son 20 séptimos 20 séptimos menos 3
séptimos en el primero y luego son 10
séptimos 10 séptimos más más dos por
tres son seis séptimos y finalmente son
diez séptimos más tres séptimos diez
séptimos
las tres séptimos y eso ya haciendo la
suma correcta nos queda aquí 20 menos 3
son 17 séptimos en el segundo son 16
séptimos verdad y en el último son 10
más 3 esos diez más 3 son 13 séptimos
esto es a equis estrella vamos ahora a
restarle b
ok entonces en realidad yo quiero
calcular la norma la norma de a x
estrella menos b ok que es el ax
estrella
ponerlo bien esto a equis estrellas son
17 séptimos 16 séptimos y 13 séptimos
aunque ya esto le debo le debo restar el
vector b que si no mal recuerdo andaba
por aquí el vector b es este que es el
214 verdad allí se encuentra entonces le
restamos 2 14
muy bien ya esto es a lo que hay que
calcularle su norma
esta es la distancia minimizada ok
porque este es x estrella la solución al
problema de mínimos cuadrados entonces
esto digamos y si lo hacemos al cuadrado
para que no haya tanto problema esto
será igual
esto será igual a la norma de que vector
bueno pues a 17 séptimos le tengo que
restar dos enteros que son 14 séptimos
eso son 17 menos 14 son 3 séptimos
déjenme poner
corchetes de vector aquí son 3 séptimos
en el segundo son 17 séptimos menos 1
que son 7 séptimos y esos son en total 9
séptimos y finalmente 13 séptimos menos
4 que son menos de 28 séptimos
eso nos da nos da menos 15 séptimos
verdad tengo aquí 13 séptimos menos 28
séptimos eso son menos y 28 menos 13 en
efecto son 15 séptimos muy bien entonces
queremos calcular la norma al cuadrado
de este vector y eso ya es algo muy
sencillo verdad aquí el cuadrado de este
son nueve y siete por siete son 49 este
es el cuadrado de la primera coordenada
más el cuadrado de la segunda que son
nueve por nueve son 81 49 ambos más 15
séptimos al cuadrado no no quiero
errarlo déjenme hacer 15 por 15 esto es
5 por 5 son 25 y llevo 25 y 2 son 7 y
luego bajo es 1 por 55 y 1 por 1 es uno
estos 5 7 y 5 son
llevo una 1 y una sorpresa si son 225 49
años entonces cuánto es
esto en total porque tenemos 81 y 9 son
90 entonces 225 más 90 son 59 y 2 son 11
llevamos una son 315 49 a vos
muy bien 315 sobre 49 entonces esta
norma es al cuadrado si yo quiero
obtener la norma real tengo que sacar la
raíz cuadrada déjenme quitar estas
operaciones que hice aquí entonces esto
será igual esto será igual a la raíz
cuadrada de esto que será la raíz
cuadrada de 315 sobre la raíz cuadrada
de 49 que es 7 ahora bien la raíz
cuadrada de 315 no sé si se ve como que
se puede simplificar por ejemplo aquí
hay un 9
y esto es 9 x 35 entonces esto es 3
veces la raíz de 35 sobre 7 muy bien el
punto es que ya no habrá un menor valor
para las distancias verdad esta es la
distancia menor entre entre lo que
podríamos esperar de lo que es una
solución así que este resultado basado
en nuestra solución por mínimos
cuadrados es el mejor estimado que
podemos tener al problema original de
encontrar la intersección de las tres
rectas aquí x igual a 10 séptimos y
igual a 3 séptimos déjenme ponerlo aquí
por ejemplo 10 séptimos será más o menos
como 1 y un cachito verdad por aquí y
luego 3 séptimos es muy poquito entonces
por aquí es que anda mi solución por
mínimos cuadrados
ok como sea espero que lo hayas
encontrado muy útil y que empieces a
apreciar que la solución por mínimos
cuadrados es de verdad una aplicación
muy útil